boa noite a todos
é primeiro que é um desafio muito grande
pra aliás antes de tudo é um enorme
prazer estar novamente aqui na água em
cascavel
e é um desafio muito grande para
oradores do ted trazer assuntos e temas
que sejam de interesse que seja
inspiradores e motivadores para a
platéia assim como também para vocês é
um desafio muito grande ficar aqui
prestar atenção e e depositar esse tempo
também investimentos que vocês nessa
noite eu queria falar que na verdade
além de uma série de outras coisas que a
gente pode pensar em conversar eu queria
primeiro falar sobre uma história na
verdade essa daqui vai ser o nosso tema
pelo menos pressa parte da da palestra e
pará aponta essa história eu queria
apresentar primeiro esse personagem que
sou eu no caso
quando eu estava pensando um pouco sobre
o que poderia falar nesse momento aqui
do ted e vendo pelo currículo poderia
pensar em falar sobre três diferentes
coisas poderia ficar falando aqui sobre
a minha ideia extraordinária da tese de
doutorado e com certeza e cinco minutos
alguns de vocês já estariam dormindo
poderia falar sobre a como manter a
sanidade durante as minhas três
graduações
há quem diga que eu sou um pouco louca
ainda eu penso na quarta graduação mas
acho que talvez esteja na hora de parar
e poderia falar sobre o lado
empreendedor de quando eu criei uma
empresa quando eu tinha 18 anos e há
exatos dez anos atrás da empresa fechou
as contas tenho 28 anos então na verdade
uma empresa não durou muito tempo não
faria sentido falar sobre isso também
então o que eu queria falar na verdade
pra vocês aqui seria a ponto a mais essa
questão do outro lado da história e
falar um pouco de quais foram os fatos e
o que aconteceu nessa minha trajetória
embora curta ainda que pra mim seja
muito que é muito inspiradora e eu
espero q pra você se possa tocar um
pouco as pessoas que estão abertas e
disponíveis a
essas novas experiências então eu queria
convidar vocês aqui eu sei que isso já
acontece bastante mas eu queria que
vocês embarcassem nessa viagem junto
comigo eu gostaria que todos aqui todo
mundo fechasse os olhos
sei que tem gente que ainda não está de
olhos fechados esperando pelos outros
mas é preciso que todos vocês estejam
fechados que vocês lembrarem a última
viagem que vocês fizeram lembrar se
dessa viagem o que foi demais diferente
nesse lugar o que pra você chamou a
atenção você está neste lugar diferente
talvez seja um lugar onde você já
tivessem passado uma outra vez que vocês
viram nesse lugar que tem emocionado
vocês o que tenha transformado essa
viagem não abre o olho ainda uma outra
pergunta gostaria que vocês lembrar-se
uma última experiência que pra você foi
muito significante algo que você tenha
feito e que você tenha sentido que de
verdade estava mudando o seu rumo de
vida é difícil né
mas pense um pouquinho mais alguma coisa
que você tenha feito que de fato você
pense hoje aquilo mudou minha vida pode
abrir os olhos
sei que muitos aqui fechar os olhos
ficaram pensando o que é comemorar que
saísse daqui ou para que falou de viagem
lembrou das férias com a família e
lembrou que na verdade estava querendo
matar um familiar naquele dia
é normal essa viagem eu estou propondo
para vocês essa reflexão não é uma coisa
assim
a gente sempre demora um pouco pra ficar
pensando em o que mexe comigo o que está
acontecendo na minha vida às vezes as
coisas são muito rotineiras automáticos
a gente não tira esse tempo pra pensar
mas isso é importante porque se essa
viagem eu estou propondo pra vocês eu
quero que vocês embarquem junto comigo e
desfrutem desses sentimentos dessas
emoções que eu quero passar para vocês
uma história que eu quero contar lá
começa com um personagem que novamente
sou eu
há 20 anos atrás vocês podem ver que era
uma criança feliz é porque uma criança
desse tamanho comia de tudo então sendo
assim não tinha como eu ser muito
infeliz mas como vocês podem observar
aqui e eu já tinha dito eu sou daqui de
cascavel soltou da região sul
sou apegado às tradições gaúchas eu me
criei dentro do centro de tradições
gaúchas ctg ne e acredita que alguns de
vocês aqui também
e uma coisa que para mim sempre foi
muito forte foi esse meu apego com a
minha tradição a minha cultura e as
minhas raízes
o ctg foi uma das maiores escolas pra
mim lá a gente não só prendia a dançar a
las a fazer artesanato reclamar e canta
principalmente eu por conta do impulso
dos meus pais estavam sempre envolvidos
em atividades sociais atividades de
destaque como não assim como tem as
primeiras prendas
a gente sempre tinha que estudar um
pouco mais pela nossa história a nossa
cultura o nosso o cloro e desde há oito
anos o que gera envolvidos em alguns
projetos sociais
é um projeto social de ensino a cultura
para crianças adolescentes e ensinar a
dançar sempre preocupados em o que vocês
estão fazendo aqui dentro que pode
afetar a sua comunidade em volta e isso
todas as crianças ctg sempre foram muito
envolvidas falta que nessa época não
fazia muitos em tudo pra mim mas não era
tão impactante mas guardem essa
informação e isso vai ser crucial no
decorrer aqui dessa história
essa foto por si só ela é carregada de
muita emoção para quem já conhece uma
outra história minha vai lembrar de um
documentário vai lembrar de uma campanha
de alguns anos atrás e é um momento em
que quando eu tinha 20 anos foi
diagnosticado com uma doença grave
crônica e por um erro de mensagem médica
eu fui que o prognóstico de que eu teria
mais dez anos de vida e adoro risos
na verdade eu sei que isso foi um erro
de mensagem
talvez um médio que tenha falado você
vai viver até 100 anos e eu só vi 10
eu me apeguei nos 10 anos e seguir a
vida o que mudou de lá pra cá
na verdade a partir daquele momento em
que eu comecei a pensar bom se eu tenho
só mais dez anos de vida o que eu vou
fazer nesses meus próximos dez anos
isso eu fui cada vez multiplicando os 10
anos
claro que não passou muito muito tempo
de lá pra cá mas o que mudou pra mim foi
que eu comecei a pensar o que eu estou
fazendo o trabalho que eu estou a
faculdade que eu estou fazendo isso tem
algum significado para mim qual é o
propósito de estar aqui já vinha fazendo
alguns trabalhos voluntários durante a
minha jornada acadêmica também e desde
já nessa época já estava quase saindo do
ctg que havia incompatibilidade de
horários mas isso voltava pra mim
a partir desse momento comecei a dar um
novo significado para as coisas que eu
fazia e as decisões que eu ia tomar
a partir disso claro como eu falei para
vocês isso já é uma coisa que é
construída da minha identidade como
criança mas ficou muito mais forte a
partir dos 20 anos um novo propósito que
aqui eu quero apresentar para vocês que
é o voluntariado desde os 8 anos eu
venho trabalhando em projetos
voluntários e ele tem se intensificado
nos últimos anos a gente pode ver como o
voluntariado cultural da época eu
ensinava crianças a dançar voluntariado
social quando já era mais velho e até as
ilhas de idosos ou disponibilizavam tem
como eu para ensinar
é pessoas mais experientes de terceira
idade pra dançar voluntariado educativo
quando o acadêmico de um dos cursos e
depois acabei virando professor também a
gente tinha um projeto para ensinar
jovens carentes de escolas públicas há
como se preparar para o primeiro emprego
voluntariado profissional e humanitário
eo global que são os últimos
e eu comecei a desenvolver e trabalhar
em ongs trabalhar em projectos
relacionados com o desenvolvimento
sustentável e os objetivos da onu e o
trabalho voluntário global é você se
inserir em algum projeto internacional
para de alguma forma as pessoas do mundo
também
eu poderia ficar aqui mais 30 minutos
falando sobre cada um desses projetos
mas eu vou me ater nos últimos que é o
voluntariado global e humanitário e aqui
eu quero trazer para vocês algumas
emoções e alguns aprendizados que eu
tive
durante esses últimos trabalhos
novamente se eu pudesse falar também das
histórias engraçadas de cada uma deles
em que teria mais algumas horas também
não vou meter alguns pontos somente o
que eu aprendi
um dos primeiros pontos e hoje as
pessoas elas dão um pouco mais de de
apelo para isso que aqui eu chamei de
humanidade é o senso de que você faz
parte de um mundo
esse mundo real e o senso de que as
pessoas que estão à sua volta elas são
tão importantes para você como você é
pra elas
a partir do momento que você começa a
viajar e conhecer diferentes culturas
diferentes países diferentes pessoas com
histórias de vida diferente você começa
a transformar também a sua vida
nesse exemplo nós temos duas artesãs uma
peruana e uma artesã árabe da região da
jordânia com a arábia saudita
as duas assim como eu tinha a minha mãe
e minha avó nos tempos do ctg se
preocupava com o apelo da sua tradição a
sua cultura desenvolver seu próprio
campeonato em casa ea diferença é que
aqui elas dependem disso para viver e os
projetos que a gente estava envolvido
para trabalhar era pra ajudar que essas
artesãs conseguissem continuar inseridas
no mercado local e regional para vender
seu artesanato e não serem combatidos
por produtos que são produzidos de forma
industrializada da china e de outros
países industrializados um dos das
coisas mais impactantes principalmente
um dos últimos projetos que eu trabalhei
que foi uma missão da pela oriente médio
ea região do norte da áfrica
é a gente toma conta de que nem tudo o
que a gente vê é real ou que tem um
outro lado da moeda
essas duas fotos aqui em cima de um
camelo na pirâmide de gizé
esse é o senhor carregando um fardo
enorme de lixo ela tem uma única
diferença
um muro só tem um muro que separa as
pirâmides do egito próximo de cairo com
a garra siri que é a cidade maior do que
cascavel virada em lixo
são mais de 300 mil pessoas que vivem
sobrevivem de cuidados de lixo e não é
lixo reciclável é lixão uma cidade maior
do que a nossa que vive em cima do lixo
isso acontece do lado de um dos lugares
mais visitados do mundo
quando a gente vai pra fazer esse tipo
de trabalho voluntário a gente descobre
também que alguns países assim como na
nossa cultura o nosso traz brasileiro
que foi durante muitos anos explorado
teve aí a seus países que conquistaram o
brasil a mesma coisa acontece com outros
países no caso do egito ele foi
explorado durante anos e hoje estão
começando a se recuperar e começar a
trabalhar também para se modernizar
infelizmente ainda é um dos cinco países
mais pobres do mundo e que carrega essas
mazelas
quando você vai para um lugar desse você
fala olha a foto aquela foto bonita do
instagram
não é só aquilo trás dela tem um outro
cenário tem uma outra vida tem mais
coisas que eu preciso conhecer e que eu
não consigo olhando só as minhas redes
sociais começa a ver que no mundo tem
muito mais coisa que você pode
e deve ver porque isso vai impactar sua
vida
uma das outras coisas que o voluntariado
a gente permite aprender e desenvolver
eu chamei aqui de resiliência na verdade
é muito mais do que isso você começa a
pensar em independência liberdade e
proatividade para algumas coisas em um
momento eu estava andando pela faixa de
gaza lotado de armamentos barreiras
militares tanques de guerra monte sinai
ainda do norte dá do egito totalmente
controlado
e você parece que eu me sinto mais
seguro lado que eu me sinto seguro no
apartamento onde mora em são paulo e as
pessoas falam ah
a violência só existe nesses lugares da
zona de conflito e não vou precisar
lugares porque é perigoso eu prefiro
ficar aqui na minha zona de conforto
aqui eu posso falar sobre desarmamento
aqui eu posso falar sobre conflitos
entre lugares diferentes e você descobre
que na verdade sem você vivencia ou sem
você pelo menos abriu seus olhos para
esses outros problemas dificilmente você
vai conseguir propor alguma coisa e
propor uma solução de melhoria
esse foi um dos outros projetos que a
gente participou também que era
relacionado com a desmilitarização e
ações de pacificação e que só vivendo
esses momentos que a gente aprende um
pouco ao quanta gente também pode mudar
o nosso jeito de pensar no nosso jeito
de agir e como também eu consigo
trabalhar na minha cidade na minha
comunidade ações para que a gente
consiga desenvolver melhor uma cópia
vida e também a qualidade da nossa
comunidade
sem dúvida essa falta aqui é uma das
mais belas eu acho que eu vi durante o
último projeto e aqui a gente fala sobre
as pessoas estão cada vez mais
procurando a sua felicidade do seu
próprio propósito
e aí vem aquela onda sobre anti
materialismo eo prémio nobel da economia
está falando sobre economia
comportamental e finanças
comportamentais ou seja nem tudo mais é
lucro nem do mais dinheiro preciso
pensar também em coisas que tragam a
felicidade diferente trabalhar com o
voluntariado eu posso garantir para
vocês que vai trazer uma série de
diferentes alegrias
por isso é que eu chamo de felicidade
relativa às vezes você pode estar em
família no almoço de família você vê que
pra você está feliz aquele momento e que
ele é passageiro
às vezes você vai estar em um outro país
você vai ser roubado vai perder todos os
seus documentos suas malas e dinheiro
melhor para seus amigos e dá risada e
você continua feliz e foi o que
aconteceu comigo também
além disso tem uma série de outros como
conhecer pessoas diferentes e conectar
novas culturas e experimentar coisas que
você não experimentar ia no seu local ou
na sua comunidade e o principal de tudo
você achar que isso não tem impacto na
vida dos outros e os outros vídeos pra
descer por você simplesmente passando
por lá
isso sem dúvida é transformador
o real destino dessa viagem que quis
falar pra vocês aqui e o principal deles
na minha visão é o autoconhecimento
muitas pessoas quando a gente fala de
trabalho voluntário vai falar mas é
bonita pessoa guardar seu dinheiro na
hora seu trabalho vai viver a vida
viajando mas só fazer voluntariado antes
conhecer outros lugares mais altos não
faz voluntariado na sua própria cidade
tem uma série de conflitos aí e há quem
diga ainda também a mas fazer um
voluntariado de ensinar inglês para
crianças carentes não geram nenhum
impacto para elas
isso gera gera muito mas acho que o
impacto maior ainda de tudo isso é
impacto na pessoa que está envolvido é
no seu processo de autoconhecimento
todos esses ensinamentos dessas emoções
relacionadas a felicidade ea resiliência
ao seu conhecimento independência tudo
está dentro de você
essa viagem outra pessoa não faz porque
é você que precisa fazer é você que vai
sentir tudo isso por isso que eu chamo
como real destino dessa viagem do
voluntariado é o seu próprio
autoconhecimento evolução crescimento
espiritual o que vocês quiserem chamar
para encerrar gostaria só de dizer que
embora em curto espaço de tempo eu
espero que vocês tenham conseguido
navegar um pouco sobre essa história
essa viagem sobre voluntariado esse
processo de autoconhecimento
eu queria só destacar aqui essa frase
que fala que nós podemos viajar por todo
o mundo em busca do que é belo
mas se já não trouxermos conosco nunca
encontraremos passamos por amor ea
recompensa com certeza será positivo e
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]